[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to walk through how to update
your Google Cloud Billing
Account and Payments
Profile settings
for self-serve accounts.
Your Billing Account and
Payments Profile work together.
The Billing Account
tracks the costs
incurred by all
attached projects
and defines who pays
for the resources.
It is connected to a
Payments Profile, which
stores your payment
instrument information
and defines how you
pay for charges.
Both your Billing Account
and Payments Profile
store several pieces
of information.
For the selection of items
highlighted in this video,
some can be changed after
initial creation and some
cannot.
To change those
items, you will need
to create a new Billing Account
and/or Payments Profile.
We will now cover how to
update changeable items
using the Cloud Console.
Get started by heading
into the Console.
Then head to the Navigation
menu in the left-hand pane.
Choose Billing, then
use the dropdown menu
to select Manage
Billing Accounts.
First, we will walk
through changes
that can be made to a
Cloud Billing Account,
including display
name and organization.
In order to perform
these tasks, you'll
need to be a Billing Account
Administrator on the Billing
Account.
Select the Billing Account
you want to update.
This will open
the Overview page.
In the left-hand nav,
choose Account Management.
At the top of the window,
you will find the option
to change the organization.
You will also see an option
to rename the Billing Account.
This name is what users see
displayed on the console
when enabling or changing
billing on projects.
Next, we will walk
through changes
that can be made to
a Payments Profile,
including billing address,
payment users, and payment
method.
A Payments Profile can be linked
to multiple payment accounts
across Google products, such as
Google Workspace, Google Cloud,
Google Ads, and more.
So keep in mind that
changes will apply
to all linked payment accounts.
In the left-hand nav,
click Payment Settings.
In the Payments
Profile section, you
will see an option to update
the business name and address.
This mailing address is the
legally registered business
address that gets
printed on invoices.
In order to change
the billing address,
you must have Edit Payment
Profile permission or Admin
With All Permissions for
the Payments Profile.
Note that permissions
for the Payments Profile
are set by visiting
pay.google.com and not using
the Google Cloud IAM service.
Next, scroll down to the
Payments User section.
Follow the link to
Manage Payments Users,
where you can add,
delete, and update
payment user details,
including contact information
and notification settings.
In order to perform
these tasks, you
must have the Manage
Users permission,
or for full capabilities, the
Admin With All Permissions
role for the Payments Profile.
Finally, to update
the payment method,
navigate to the Payment Method
page using the left-hand nav.
Here you can update your
primary payment method
and add new payment methods.
In order to manage
payment methods,
you must be an admin with all
permissions for the Payments
Profile.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]